en el centro de españa ha aparecido este
monumento megalítico el dolmen de
guadalperales pero lleva allí desde el
año 5000 antes de cristo la península
ibérica' está en su nivel más seco en
1200 años por lo que estos restos
arqueológicos han emergido por cuarta
vez desde que fueron inundados en 1963
en un proyecto de desarrollo rural de la
dictadura de francisco franco los
arqueólogos aprovechan para estudiar lo
que hace miles de años fue un cementerio
colectivo una sorpresa porque es una
oportunidad única de volver a valorar un
sitio que no se había valorado y el
hecho de volverlo a ver pues supone eso
uno volver a tener una oportunidad que
no habíamos tenido en el pasado
ni whatsapp ni palomas mensajeras en
alemania se han encontrado mensajes que
vienen del pasado están tallados en
rocas a lo largo del río rhin con la
sequía están emergiendo se las conoce
como piedras del hambre ya que contienen
advertencias y recordatorios de
dificultades algunas datan del siglo 15
una especie de alerta apocalíptica entre
los mensajes si me ves llora
pero en europa no solo están apareciendo
mensajes esto es el lago garda de italia
el más grande y visitado del país aquí
ha emergido una playa de rocas accesible
para el turismo mientras la mitad del
territorio europeo se encuentra en
peligro por las sequías